we want to be your friend we want to be
your partner but if you want to make
China a hostile country you have to bear
the consequences a stark warning as
hostilities over Hong Kong grow now Arau
over technology looming the UK likely to
reverse a decision to allow Chinese
giant Huawei into its 5g network the
Ambassador clear that would hurt the
consequences that there might be many
first eight damage
breaking Britain's image as a open
business friendly free environment
transparent environment as they claim to
be but punish your image as a country
which can conduct independent policy
means you Sikkema sir come to a foreign
pressure you know you can't make your
own independent foreign policy I always
say Britain and only be great
one they can have their independent
foreign policy if you do not have an
independent policy you have to dance to
the tune other countries words perhaps
designed to alert a leader who's all
about bringing back control but the
decision on Huawei isn't free from
external forces sanctions imposed on the
firm by the US are impacting on Boris
Johnson's choices pressure from Tory
politicians also a factor that is the
wider issue there also technological
concerns as well any policy change on
Huawei should come before Parliament
breaks up for the
summer an important moment that could
leave Britain's relations with China
broken for far longer
Deborah Haynes Sky News